buenas tardes andrés como dices estamos
aquí en el centro en el parque de los
periodistas a escasos metros de la plaza
de bolívar donde ha tenido lugar esa
ceremonia solemne aquí los ánimos ya se
empieza a retirar la gente tras el fin
de la ceremonia pero ha habido mucha
emoción ha habido lágrimas también
gritos ha habido bailes compañados
también por grupos culturales también la
presencia de grupos indígenas de la
minga indígena
afrodescendiente es la verdad una fiesta
del pueblo en esta primera toma
presidencial
que se ha celebrado junto al pueblo ya
que normalmente estas ceremonias estaban
reservadas únicamente para los invitados
se calcula más de 100.000 personas aquí
en el centro de bogotá con más de 15 mil
efectivos de las fuerzas de seguridad
hemos hablado con mucha gente en la
plaza de bolívar por ejemplo un señor de
la costa caribe llevaba desde las 6 de
la mañana esperando para poder ver al
presidente gustavo petro y es que para
muchas personas eso una larga espera
después de que la izquierda nunca ha
gobernado en colombia' los gritos los
jaleos más importantes se los han
llevado durante la ceremonia 'francia
márquez también el momento en el que
maría josé pizarro le ha puesto la banda
presidencial a gustavo petro y de las
presencias internacionales gabriel boric
también se ha llevado buenas aplausos
cabe destacar también que ha habido un
grito recurrente tanto lo hemos
escuchado en voz de roy barreras el
presidente del congreso pero también
aquí con la gente que ha estado presente
del si se pudo y sobre todo el momento
que más expectación ha tenido aquí entre
los presentes es cuando gustavo petro la
primera orden que ha hecho como
presidente es pedir que le traigan la
espada de bolívar que ha dicho que va a
ser para proteger al que la va a
entregar al pueblo y también cabe
destacar que gustavo petro
el primer presidente ex guerrillero de
colombia y francia- márquez
afrodescendiente y lideresa ambiental en
un día histórico aquí en bogotá